coût pour vos interventions moi je
voudrais répondre à la première question
vous dites que les associations
féministes qui travaillent sur le
terrain
en tant que chercheur nous allons sur le
terrain en tant que chercheur en
sciences sociales cercle par exemple mon
terrain a duré trois ans quatre ans le
terrain de mai mais contrairement aux
associations notamment les associations
elles ne font remonter la parole qui
sont des gens qui vont vers les
associations vont vers les associations
dont six sont des entrepreneurs de cause
les associations qu'on parle en
sociologie ce sont des entrepreneurs de
cause elles sont là pour essayer de
peser sur le débat public est justement
fonctionner faire peser sur le cadrage
d'un problème public or les associations
dès lors en fonction du cadrage qu'elles
imposent elles vont faire remonter des
paroles qui sont en forme avec avec leur
cadrage et donc les parce que des
personnes qui vont s'adresser aux
associations vont aller vers les
associations qui sont en adéquation avec
leur situation et leur cadrage donc que
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
quand j'ai écouté la table ronde de la
fois c'était que des associations
abolitionnistes
donc elles ne font remonter qu'une forme
de parole parce que les perses les
personnes qui vivent là la pornographie
d'une manière qui ne sera pas conforme
avec celle la parole portée par ses
soeurs nous soutenons pas ne se
tourneront pas à faire cette association
est donc nous alors que nous en tant que
chercheur on va dans tous les terrains
et je les dis dans une partie de mon
terrain j'ai parlé de cette catégorie
des phénix je les dis ce sont des
acteurs économiques acteurs aux sciences
hausse en ce sens social c'est pas le
tance deux acteurs et actrices de films
pornographiques sont des acteurs
investis dans une activité qui sont
borderline sur plein de points mais là
comme le disait julie on a les mène en
année on a le cadre juridique pour
appliquer pour lutter contre ces
infractions pour lui
[Musique]